hey guys merry here on gamespot com and
we are showcasing games done quick we're
gonna have a bunch of speedrunners
playing games fast for your pleasure and
I am joined by oh we have so many people
we have the lovely Alex new house yeah
you look good to have you back and we
will also have studio here you are gonna
be our speed runner today for round
about eSports mode eSports mode and
hooligan just hanging out probably laugh
at this poking studio with a stick if he
messes up this is a game that not only
have I not seen played in any kind of
speedrun capacity before I didn't even
know that this was a thing that people
speed ran until this day so I'm really
stoked to show you guys I think a lot of
people actually are unfamiliar with
roundabout in general a lot of people
this kind of gone under the radar but
it's pretty wild concept of a limo that
spins around and you know I think that's
pretty much all you need to say yeah
that narrows everything down like no
explanation needed besides that it's a
limo it will spin a lot and we'll do a
few things to make it go fast okay if we
know it spins fast but can we drive fast
that's the question so first you need to
you know put up the proper settings
awesomeness detection very important is
a lot oh good tactics that I'm not aware
of and this is roundabout mode I need to
demonstrate it really quickly it just
friends everything into part sounds and
it's actually overwhelmingly loud in
game because the audio don't equalize
for it so they'll be overwhelmed within
seconds by the parts and overwhelmingly
but all right now Geoffrey the skeleton
will tell us what it's time for when do
we start the timer there will be a
countdown timer in game and I'll say
start to but don't get a lot of
indicators let's go Georgie yo yes we
won't see a lot of live action that's
pretty much area yeah this game has a
live-action cutscenes are amazing and
time starts now
Oh roundabout is a game about a
revolving limousine too fast for the
checkpoint there and right now this is
on a nuke like a new game+ file I have
wait I'm going achievements for this oh
yeah I got the rotative speed McCool so
I have an ability that lets me shrink
the limousine and it will always turn
like there is no way to stop from
turning you can go slower but you still
have to turn going on lumigan can also
jump by the way it sounds more wonder
then yes jumping is actually not a good
thing to do for the most part I use it
if I need to get over obstacles and
sometimes kind of as a risky
get-out-of-jail-free card how come do
you slow down when you land you slow you
slow down when you're in the air
specifically and you don't have control
the rotation because of the facets going
yeah so you became a tiny limo that's
going to get me through a lot of narrow
quarters I'll use up for most of the run
because if I don't it's almost
impossible to like speak to stuff
quickly this game also is very violent
roundabout town does not have very good
lobster going to the streams here your
wheels are covered in cali mm-hmm a lot
of jelly clearly jelly no didn't expect
it to be such a violent game and have
such a friendly demeanor yeah your tires
have read it's just a happy-go-lucky
game until you run over dozens of
pedestrians dozens is kind of an
understatement you know this is really
this is why side you can see it right
here yes people thought crazy taxi was
bad crazy uber black is like the worst
this is just really horrible limo of
death killing everyone so I hope you
guys hear this on stream allah pink sony
put a bunch the controller to the lab
there's a really loud xbox simple
receipt for this which this makes it
perfect because it like is this beast of
destruction and death that I just
freaking out non-stop it vibrates like
crazy in the skin so that last stuff was
intentional it lets be skipped part of
the traversal of yoga world so these
ports fever mode is actually just the
normal game in terms of like missions
put us all into one continuous like
check my system so if there are times
where I wouldn't be in a mission because
I just completed one that I can
sometimes these death the good parts
game they're at in October mailboxes to
win the favor of a rich developer that
was annoyed that people live near him of
course also this is the Blues Brothers
segment I like the stuff of commentary
in this game it's light but they're ever
so slight very subtle for the most part
very the most tricky because I can't
jump in here and there's lots of very
narrow passages what inspired you to
speedrun this game
so no I had that question inspired um I
saw this for the first time on giant
bomb actually needed a quick lift with a
danke bill and I found out this game has
a lot of people that I've seen on the
internet before on videos like commuting
many bought psychedelic eyeball whoever
the actors yes like the characters and
actually just voices for this game right
and like they were part of the game like
I have to find this like I I've known
these guys for the years in terms of
stuff they put out and then I started
playing it I really liked it just
because I mean this is amazing how could
you not like this is amazing this is a
perfect video game perfect game and I'm
doing Stan yes and I just I just kept
rolling with it the gameplay is actually
really fun for this like to go fast in
this game you have to really like take
into account a lot the rotation there
should be no doubt there's a lot of
skill involved in this game I saw this
game two years ago I think at an indie
mix it was the media India exchange as
the party where they have like it media
people and then Indies get to show off
their new game something you might not
have ever heard of and I came across
this game of course even just looking at
it you have to pick it up it's the most
interesting thing I think I'd seen in
years and I couldn't believe it but what
I wasn't ready for was the amount of
skill that it does take to get through
some of these areas so it's a funny game
it's a silly game it doesn't take itself
itself too seriously but with that I
mean there's an exceptional amount of
skill especially in this particular mode
that you're playing yeah and the
optimization is all so insane because
theoretically if you do everything
perfectly there is no randomness to it
there's nothing that's really up the
chance outside of probably some of the
death warps it's actually kind of hard
to kill yourself sometimes but you could
do if you do this perfectly and have
everything planned out but the second
you slow down to second drop rhythm
you're pretty much adapting that stop
right for the rest of the entire road
yeah if there's a few learning segments
where everything's reset but I mean
there's two of them
you really don't have a chance to to
play casually to kind of relax for me to
run right now we're in a head-to-head
race with that limo that is rotating
over there I've one day on and this is a
segment that I had one full with lately
oh no this augurs oh we're not here to
kill them we're gonna play soccer no
mercy they just wanted to play soccer
when they got ran over by limo they
played the game of their lives I should
have thought of that before if that was
like one of the worst inspirational
children sports movies I've ever seen no
to get the yellow circle checkpoint do
you have to touch it or just if you were
over it in any way like if you jump over
it as that there is a slight bit of
height you can work with okay so that
one for example I wasn't on the ground
level but you can't be too high up still
I jump on I should have jumped got
punished for it this game is incredibly
punishing that regard this leg at second
with texts actually very tricky because
if you want to go fast you might have to
jump over the cars right down in that
sense yeah and there's also a bunch of
with Makana lights that block that walk
away like cars are a big problem but the
light post and it being even more
dangerous because it's gonna block all
the jumps at least you can play yeah
well you see him go around like a boat
yep I actually use that in a later which
is a so I need to pick up the flotation
operate now okay which is gonna be
tricky because I have to do this next
section be great if I could shrink but
and sell just do a couple of jumps in
use careful navigation and positive law
very very careful very careful now
it's the serious stuff here you have to
balance like all this strategy careful
maneuvering and laughter because see my
problem is I tend to go for it too much
and I'm just like I can do this I can
make this move is there ever a time when
dying actually is a strat yes right
there that one right there right then
yeah um right tell us that so that we
know how great you are um if you ever
see me die it was on purpose okay gotcha
yeah oh yeah we're in a race right now
and we just took third okay by
eliminating the competition nice job
excellent very well done it was a
triathlon which is why we need to go in
the water and now I can use the shrink
upgrade again ty are those there in like
it's art mater how are smarter this is
foldable I'm very untrue I don't know
anything about our so it's probably why
it recognized that so this is this
little passive you can take you actually
have to buy it which isn't a problem
really because you can buy instantly and
if you're doing a new game run you can
earn enough money by just getting a big
combo and not getting hit which will be
relevant and awesome names I'm playful
we're showing the cutscenes or a Summer
Games I'm quick I just probably the
wrong marathon well no that's a good
marathon to you that they're both pretty
phenomenal so we are now back in the
death race with the Alamo this summer
actually gonna kill him but it's a
cutscene that we unfortunately won't see
and it's going to be once we enter this
tunnel and because we killer our
opponent and destroyers car which is the
real crime roundabout town has very
strict car description rules we are
banished to the mountains well we're
actually bring for the police and I and
I started the level in the air which
you're not supposed to do also I lost
all my paint and uh and you hat yeah my
hats done oh no you got we're gonna have
to customize something to tell or the
car has customized me
run so no what's important here so right
now we could be damned i look like [ __ ]
I have no Oh been out of Washington okay
oh sweet I was a close one I mean it
that's why you couldn't you messed up a
lesson yeah I needed I needed my my look
at using my stuff pretty important okay
I can't harvest quorum without my hot
dog dad have the most important
speedtech really Oh change camera angles
oh yeah so there's a there's a few
sections like that where we'll give you
like a top-down perspective and it's
usually just to make a little bit easier
because you're you're navigating
something else at vertical piece yeah
the movement would it work normally with
the standard camera roundabout mountain
has a lot more I'd say pipe passages and
it's like a lot more that can really
bump me once the problem is when you hit
something sometimes you lose control it
depends on how you hit it so if i'm like
stuck between two things for example you
know i'm not escaping guaranteed yeah
i'm not sure what actually killed me
there because i shouldn't've been dere
anything because that coffin the coffins
what did you see I got a buzz around
those would kill you it's getting real
yeah so there's a priest in our car at
this point you can be scared of
skeletons because Jeffrey the skeleton
who we met in the opening of course of
course yes yes when I sin has introduced
himself I like it the way it is skokie
really Austin Powers yourself or you're
like stuck between two walls and you can
do anything sort of if that happens and
I just called myself or just go for
something there an auto detonate know
you will for you just blood into stuff
yeah like it's very fast too in other
words playing again yeah yeah move
really
every time had a green circle I'm going
to repair my car so that's why I'm able
to take a cue that's every now and then
not that many of so that's one of the
nastiest checkpoints because there's a
good chance at the car on it so some
like at this point this is where like
the optimization is intense because you
need to kind of track where the cars are
going to be and that's that's on a
global timer that's always moving so if
i if i'm off at all that i might have
bad car positioning small tiny area no
the purposeful doesn't work ok we're all
good guys all right I just know that's
not really what did that death due to do
it got me closer to the next checkpoint
because I just finish the last mission
and normally that system respond point
alright that jumps kind of tight you
want to jump before you go off the ledge
you can follow up ledges in this game
but you tend to get yourself some lay
down and die anyways and so I dumped a
little bit too early there but so does
check mine yeah I think those dogs
there's not dogs you can hit though ok
so Mary are gonna say well I don't know
if we could forensic we're not monsters
I mean the pedestrians are walking in
the most street so you know we're
finally noticed by the police for our
actions grand great trigger them they
did their duty as expected beautifully
on time
this whole thing seems incredibly
precision bass like I don't feel like
you ever get to breathe during this I
mean it's it's a short run and it's a
run where like it I'm going for a better
time I'd be crying to get out in the
first level for the most part and it's
like it's fun but it's definitely
stressful to go for really good times
like I love playing steam casually but
when I want to go at it hard cause it's
like this is a good game but schemes
also really hard and also some of the
death warps are kind of annoying just
because you can get it while you can't
see your character and it can be hard to
control over this section there's
actually some speed back so it's okay
down there I need to be a for HP your
car key ticket I'll purpose on purpose
your car can take a total of four hits
then on the fifth hit it works club ok
so I wanted to take a single bunk if I
can there we go probably really hard to
stick one hit yeah it definitely can be
harder than anticipated so we're fine
the police and that cop car should blow
up instantly and then I'm teleport over
here beside great it's also the fast way
to fight the police why is there police
car just on an iceberg right there to
red card
don't our lowest dedicated police Droid
find out some things happen twenty
minutes later when they arrived on scene
they are on those icebergs waiting for
ya I call that the guy with a hunch I
have a feeling they're gonna show up on
a Berg and I'm gonna be ready for you
anything happens I'm gonna be here
already here on this ice center if you
need me by myself or I missed cliff time
is coming up pretty soon well we're
gonna have the hardest part of the game
to control oh man I always save the
hardest for last ok I have to drive
normally Oh what and it's actually the
controller god-awful you're having to
fight your primal instincts to spend
that's actually part there we go teen on
the button and we're rewarded with this
great nation shut us to Paris you people
19 fmd tough same [ __ ] and actually uh
this is all the cares this is a desert
bus simulator which let's skip the
credits we can go ahead actually play
this I never want to leave or you know
the next forever is the only video game
uni in your life like play challenge and
it's just this for hours and hours and
hours and hours just try not to drift
off the road don't forget to go strange
the meaning of life oh no oh no no okay
what about those round about Syria I was
pretty cool I've never seen anything
like that like that game itself is
really unique and to see it speedrun is
pretty much unheard of so what's your
best time it's about 12 minutes in game
time this game doesn't have been a
community where we don't know that the
in game timer is actually accurate but
whatever is our response to that good
it's roundabout route about yeah he
cares this is all for just the fun yeah
enjoyment alstyne reading is purely for
the enjoyment and not actually for being
number one the world record for this buy
a new order who the paris clan as you
can see on the game is actually like
it's really fun to watch because it's
almost at the level of precision where
it's a hundred percent accurate and it's
really cool but it's also i mean it's a
hard thing to grind out and i give them
all the credit for really going that far
into the game what's amazing well thanks
for that stoom you guys like
speedrunning just like that you're going
to see so much more of it on the summer
games done quick 2015 let's pull up that
graphic july 26 through august first
will they be playing games non-stop
throughout all those days the entire
time for your viewing pleasure and you
are able to donate all proceeds going to
doctors without borders so it's a lot of
fun and it's for a good cause there's no
reason not to check it out i suggest you
do it